and president trump also spent his day  contacting our nation's troops  well it may be thanksgiving here in the  states the mission doesn't end overseas  but for soldiers stationed in syria it's  the little things that count  dinner is all take away this year and  soldiers are kept apart  many have seen the effects of covid 19  on their bases  for medical officers their primary  concern was once  combat injuries now it's quarantining  the sick  covet has really united us as a humanity  on this base  as opposed to all of our individual  units it's really in a lot of ways  brought us together  in a way that i never could have  imagined for those still deployed they  hope that covet is gone by the time they  get home  the u.s is expected to withdraw about  500 of the 3 thousand troops currently  based in iraq  about a thousand are still serving in  syria